la meilleure solution pour nous c'est
d'aller d'aller à paris et puis après
parvis enchaîner tout de suite pour
propos la havane
c'est une bonne solution parce que dans
la caraïbe avec tout le pays plus
matériel que nous transportant les
veuves et les vélos coutière on peut
annoncer le puits de vélo surtout du
contre-la-montre entre 7 a eu mille
euros les nouvelles routes c'est un peu
près le même prix avec le cast du
matériel c'est pas évident a donc opté
pour cette solution de passer paoli sur
un gros bol ça sera plus reposant pour
les garçons et puis notre matériel
on voyagera en toute sécurité c'est un
long périple j'espère que le résultat
sera à l'affiché pour se donner tant de
mal tu de sacrifices points et d'un
championnat du monde
quelque part c'est ce que je dis à mes
garçons du résultat du résultat surtout
nous sommes détenteurs du titre quoi des
seigneurs et aussi le podium des espoirs
avec nous bull chez les seniors avec
mikel san islas avec les derrières
cadets aussi jeunes qui progressent le
jeune algier killian je pense que notre
délégation sera plus au rendez vous